people of the internet's retroreckon
tour here and today we're taking a look
at the 10 most
terrifying enemies from the brand new
elden ring trailer
at number one we have harry potter and
the goblet head of fire did you put your
neighbor to global fire harry
no dumbledore we're gonna remain calm
here okay for real though this dude has
a freaking giant
gold goblet for a head and it's on fire
like
where is his weak point we can't shoot
him in the eye or wait for him to blink
what do we do here call down water from
above maybe we just have to wait for it
to rain
moving on to number two if you're
thinking you've seen this demented face
before it's probably because
you have at least if you're a spongebob
fan because it's squidward's house
and in this shot from the trailer it
appears to be hurtling at breakneck
speed straight for the player and it
does not look happy
now for number three here's when things
really start to get scary with white
walker tormund
look let's be real here anyone who's
seen game of thrones knows how
incredibly dominant tormund was as a
fighter now imagine how deadly he'd be
as a white walker instead
perhaps this is a hint to tormund's
ultimate fate in the winds of winter or
maybe it's just a nod one one
number four is the creepy hand spider
look apparently elden ring has a thing
for hands i don't get it but what i can
tell you is the way these fingers move
in this ever so brief clip is absolutely
terrifying
spiders are creepy in their own right
but now we have a spider just made of
fingers like i mean is there a head in
here somewhere does it have
venom i have so many questions now not
to be outdone by the creepy hand spider
we have even
more fingers getting in on the action
with number five i'm calling him mr
all the hands i mean look at this guy
why in the world would anyone possibly
need that many hands
you know what don't answer that for
number six it's cersei
and the mountain as if white walk or
tormund wasn't enough it looks like
we'll also have to take on cersei and
her zombified bodyguard during our elden
ring adventure
while they may not compare in terms of
overall size and scale to some of the
other enemies
as a team they could be pretty
formidable next it's the spike stomach
guys
i actually kind of feel bad for these
dudes i mean look they look so miserable
here
at some point they're going to just
absolutely lose their cool and rip these
spikes completely out of their stomach
then they'll probably keep the chains
use them as whips with the spikes still
attached and then work as a team to kill
us
over and over and over again at number
eight we have
chamber pot hens i told you this game is
obsessed with hands
now that i think about it wait wait wait
we're after the elven ring in this game
you guys
oh my gosh i think i get it now where
after the ring rings are worn on
hands which means i just figured out the
final boss
[Laughter]
anyway chamber pot hands probably won't
be very difficult to kill but you just
know they'll be one of the most annoying
enemies in the game
poison debuff frenzy inducing lock it in
they're 100 guaranteed to be one of
those trash enemies we hate to face and
choose to sprint by them instead
i'm looking at you blighttown now at
this point maybe george started to run
out of ideas because at number nine it's
none other than harry potter's patronus
no word yet on if dementors are in the
game but if so they'll want to steer
clear of this stack that's so clearly a
manifestation of all that is good and
happy in the world
honestly though i really do love the
visual effects here and the overall
aesthetics of this enemy or maybe it's a
friend
that'd be pretty cool and at number 10
it's the lightning
wielder as if fire breathing dragons
weren't cool enough miyazaki has decided
to also give this dragon the ability to
literally
rip a bolt of lightning out of the sky
to use
as a weapon oh and he still breathes
fire too
let me know which enemy you can't wait
to face down in the comments below and
as
always thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon